Vous reconnaissez sûrement l'endroit, nous sommes ici pour la partie 3 de la pêche à l'aimant dans la ville de Lattes
On a les autorisations pour tenter une dernière fois de retrouver les objets que l'on cherche
Et surtout le chargeur de pistolet perdu par un gendarme en sauvant une personne de la noyade
Oui le fameux
On l'a déjà dit, mais la gendarmerie a plongé pendant 1 jour pour le retrouver
Maintenant c'est notre troisième tentative
On ne va pas cherche seuls, puisque Vincent est avec nous
Et on va aussi avoir de la main d'œuvre gratuite avec les ados de la ville qui vont nous aider
Donc on les attends là
Je pense qu'on va le trouver
Bonjour
Voilà les renforts
Enchantés
Alors, qu'est-ce que Vincent a trouvé ?
Attends ne bouge pas
C'est bon tu l'as
Belle découverte, une table
Vous pêcher bien !
Ouais ouais merci !
Maintenant il faut trouver le parasol qui va au dessus
Des clefs de voiture et une lampe
C'est une opel
Bravo belle trouvaille
C'est moi qui ai fait la plus belle trouvaille de vous tous
Allez je te le vide
Ils ont accroché ensembles leurs deux aimants
Oh non les gars
Mais non mais c'est lui !
Il l'a jeté sur le mien
A, c'est lui qui a tiré en dernier ?
Oui c'est lui
Alors c'est de sa faute
Vous avez quand même des choses
Un leurre de pêche
Et là regardez, une antenne de voiture, original
Une munition et une pièce dans un sachet
Ouais elle était coincée dans le sac
C'est une munition à blanc ça
Bon courage en tout cas
Merci
Vincent a quelque chose
ça c'est du couteau !
C'était un couteau multifonctions, tu as autre chose là
Sûrement décapsuleur
Bien joué
Je le montre aux jeunes et je te la ramène
Le bois est mort
Regarde Rasta
Oh no il est dans la boulangerie, Quentin !
Il y a Rasta dans la boulangerie
Il est entré !
Rasta
Viens ici
On va essayer de ce côté si ça vous dit
On va regarder ce que Lucas nous a trouvé
Une table entière
ça c'est original
Qui fait mieux que moi ?
Il faut faire mieux que moi et ma table de jardin
Elle est en bon état celle là
Ah ouais
Regardez c'est exactement la même que le restaurant
Tu pourras la ramener chez toi celle là
Tes parents seront contents
Ouais première trottinette !
Bien joué
Allez la démonstration
Freestyle
C'est bon elle marche
Encore une trouvaille de Lucas
Là c'est lourd
Tu veux un coup de main ?
Il y a une autre table
Enfin je ne sais pas
Ouais c'est une autre table
Tu la tiens là ?
Attention c'est lourd
Ne t'inquiètes pas Lucas, lâche
Oh il y a une pièce
Attends la barre est coincée dessus
On lâche et je vais la tenir comme ça
ici il y a beaucoup de mobilier
Et ouais
Oh non elle est tombée la barre
C'est pas grave on va la repêcher après
bien joué
Je suis dessus aussi
ça vient
C'est vraiment lourd
Allez, allez,
ça y est il est sorti de la vase
Mais non...
Oh
Allez attention
Je viens t'aider ?
Ouais
Vas y
C'est super lourd
Une poubelle !
Je me bats avec une poubelle depuis tout à l'heure !
On va avoir besoin d'aide là
Tiens là tiens là
C'est bon
Il faut qu'elle se vide
On a besoin d'aide ici
Attention aux doigts
je vais l'attraper par la poignée là
Ouais !
Bien joué !
bravo
Je suis dessus depuis 30 minutes !
Maintenant on va regarder quand même s'il n'y a pas un truc à l'intérieur
On la fait basculer
Rien dans la poubelle ?
J'espère
C'est bon, elle est vide
Personne ne devra aller chez le psychologue à la fin de la journée
ça va ils travaillent bien
On a pas encoure trouvé le chargeur mais on avance sur ce sujet là
ça mord ?
j'espère
2 francs ?
Ouais
Ah ouais
1979, pas mal
On va avoir assez de mobilier pour une maison
Surveille ton vocabulaire
Désolé mais c'est lourd
Oh vélo
Attendez on va le nettoyer
Joli les gars bravo
Ouais !
Bien joué
Allez vas y
Allez à deux
C'est peut-être encore une table
Vous allez peut-être avoir besoin du grapin
Une table ?
Non
Peut-être une bouche d'égout
On dirait une altère
Ah oui c'est un pied de parasol
On va ouvrir un restaurant
regarde tu peux te mettre dessus et tourner
J'ai une planche comme ça chez moi
T'en as d'autres des idées comme ça ?
Au bord de l'eau c'est mieux
Ouais vraiment super idée
C'est une catastrophe, Arthur
C'est normal de ne pas réussir à l'enlever
Le plus simple c'est de faire ça
Ouais aussi
Attention
je crois que c'est encore un pied de parasol
Ouais ?
Eux aussi ils ont trouvé le même
Ils ont besoin d'aide peut-être, non ?
Je vais y aller
Vous y arrivez ?
Bien joué, attention à la boue
C'est quoi ça ?
Un pieds de parasol
Remplis d'eau
Encore pareil ou pas ?
Et pareil...
Le troisième pied de parasol
Ah ça vient
Tu l'as sorti de la vase
Alors qu'est-ce qu'il nous trouve de beau Vincent ?
Une table ou une vélo non ?
Ouah, il ne manquait plus que ça !
J'arrive attendez
Ne t'inquiètes pas
C'est récent, on voit encore sa couleur
couleur vase
On va le faire basculer
Et voilà
Fais tomber la boue
Rolala j'avais pas vu le trou plein d'eau
belle trouvaille
C'est vrai qu'il nous manquait le caddy
C'est le 6-ème de la journée ?
Ouais je crois
Et ouais
Le sixième pied de parasol identique
Pour de bon, on va les vendre en lot
T'as besoin d'un autre aimant ?
Vas y tout doucement
je vais essayer d'attraper le bout
C'est bon ?
Ouais, on va le laisser se vider dans l'eau
On l'a là je pense
Je crois que c'est bon
Oh il y a un truc à l'intérieur
On voit les poches, il est remplis d'eau
Attention à vous
j'espère qu'il reste quelques papiers
Oh oui !
Une carte d'identité
Incroyable
C'est bon ça
Un briquet
Une montre
Une montre carrément
Des ciseaux, il stylo plume
C'est fou ça
peut-être qu'il n'a même pas été volé et est tombé d'un bateau
Ouais clairement
Il reste des papiers ?
Il y a une carte d'identité mais il est volé parce que il n'y a pas le porte feuilles
Ouais je pense
Donc c'est volé
Ils prennent le porte feuille et laissent tout ce qui ne leur sert à rien
Fais voir la montre
C'est une super montre
C'est une bonne marque ça
Certus ?
Certus c'est une bonne marque je crois
C'est la meilleure trouvaille de la journée, bravo
Certus tu dis ?
On va pouvoir restituer la monte à la personne grâce à la carte d'identité
ça c'est fou
J'ai un stylo
Ils habitent à Lattes en plus
il y avait ça aussi
Ah un médaillon
C'est religieux visiblement
tiens prends ça avec
Ils habitent à Lattes, on va leur ramener aujourd'hui
Tu penses ?
Quand tu pêches mais que tu dois soulager un besoin naturel
ça ne se fait pas ça
belle pêche ou pas ?
Très belle pêche
On va essayer de ramener la montre, j'ai appelé sur leur numéro mais ils n'ont pas répondu
Il y a leur adresse sur la carte d'identité, alors on va tenter
Et après on embarque tout ça dans la camionnette
Vincent vient de nous faire remarquer quelque chose de difficile à croire
Je pense que vous avez déjà tous essayé
Mais vous êtes peux à avoir réussi
Du coup il faut le garder en trophée je pense
C'est un caddy infini
Un vrai caddy volé
C'est ça
Ils n'ont même pas eu besoin d'un jeton
Je pense qu'il faut le garder du coup
garde le
Allez
Je le rentre dans l'audi
C'est cadeau
c'est un beau cadeau ?
Allez merci les gars
on a essayé de venir sonner une première fois
Même si je pense que c'est juste symbolique vu l'état des objets
Mais on va essayer de nouveau de sonner
Sinon il y a les voisins au pire
On fait aussi des vidéos, c'est pour cette raison qu'on filme
Voilà, on restitue les objets aux voisins, qui vont leur transmettre les objets
Peut-être que la montre a tout de même un peu de valeur
ce serait intéressant de voir depuis quand le sac a disparu
Oui depuis quand il a été volé
C'est pour ça qu'on aurait aimé les rencontrer
Je dirais que ça fait quelques mois
je pense que le sac a main a été volé à l'arraché
Puisqu'il était plein mais bon...
Vous nous laissez vos coordonnée
Ouais on ne sait jamais
Comme ça ils peuvent nous contacter
C'est vous qui ramassez les objets avec des aimants c'est ça ?
Oui c'est ça
Et vous l'avez trouvé ou le sac ?
Dans le port de Lattes
Vus avez déjà peut-être vu nos vidéos là bas
Oui j'ai déjà vu
Vous filmez là du coup ?
Oui oui mais on peut flouter
Comme vous voulez
c'est que je viens de me réveiller !
Quelques jours après les propriétaires nous ont rappelé et nous ont donné quelques explications
sur ce mystérieux sac
Ils ont donc été cambriolés il y a 10 ans
pendant qu'ils étaient absents, le sac a main a été dérobé
Ainsi que des ordinateurs portables
Quelques jours après ce cambriolage, une carte bleue a été retrouvée flottant dans le port de la ville
Ils avaient été prévenus par la ville
Et il a donc fallut 10 ans de plus pour repêcher le sac
Malheureusement le chargeur du gendarme n'a toujours pas refait surface
ça devient compliqué, alors on va laisser cet objectif de côté
On aura tout de même fait 3 belles sessions à cet endroit
Et je suis sûr qu'il en reste encore
Et on vous dit à la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle session de pêche à l'aimant
Bonne soirée !